alors dans ce monde où il ya des
problèmes si grave
autant de femmes n'ont même pas le la
liberté de choisir leur vie on peut se
poser la question est ce que le sujet
des femmes et du pouvoir n'est pas un
sujet secondaire
il ya quelques mois une jeune femme m'a
contacté je ne la connaissais pas elle
m'a dit tout la passion qu'elle avait
pour la cause des femmes puis elle m'a
parlé de son projet c'était le projet de
créer le énième réseaux féminins dont
l'objectif était d'aider les femmes des
grandes entreprises à accéder au comité
de direction
la proposition de valeur était simpliste
il s'agissait de vendre à ces femmes en
général diplômé de grande école une
formation une formation pour apprendre à
se vendre à se présenter à négocier
enfin toutes ces choses absolument
indispensable pour leur carrière que
leurs homologues masculins eux se réfère
totalement naturellement l'anecdote m'a
paru à la fois insignifiante et
révélatrice sur le sujet des femmes et
de l'ambition je pense qu'aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une situation à la fois
d'infantilisation est aussi d'enlisement
à force de chercher des explications
on a fabriqué des excuses et le discours
des femmes et de la parité dans les
entreprises a finalement rationaliser la
non prise de risque
pour beaucoup de femmes qui pourtant
aurait une qui sont un refus d'obstacle
par rapport à l'ambition qui est
pourtant un sujet légitime pour la
plupart d'entre elles le monde bouge il
bouge profondément une bouge vite les
gens qui sont au pouvoir aujourd'hui ont
la capacité d'influencé demain de
construire demain si les femmes ne sont
pas au pouvoir
si elle ne participe pas à ces
transformations non seulement le monde
de demain aura très peu de chances
d'être plus favorables aux femmes mais
en plus je le crois profondément le
monde de demain sera moins bien que si
elle avait contribué
construire mon premier ma première
intervention sur les femmes et le
pouvoir des femmes une ambition a lieu
il ya 20 ans c'était à barcelone c'était
une convention de femmes chez ibm à haut
potentiel qui venaient de toute l'europe
l'entreprise était en profonde mutation
et le président de l'époque lou gerstner
mettait beaucoup d'énergie à faire
progresser la diversité dans les rangs
du haut management de l'entreprise et en
particulier ils mettaient beaucoup
d'énergie à faire progresser le nombre
de femmes
il ne le faisait pas parce que il
voulait il voulait être conformes je ne
sais quel standard externe qui lui
seraient imposées il le faisait parce
que ils étaient convaincus qu ibm avait
failli mourir de la trop grande au
milieu homo gênés it et de sa culture de
la pensée unique de son management et
que les organisations riche d'une grande
diversité d'opinions d'expérience
sensibilité avec plus de chances de
survivre sur le long terme
je me souviens de cette intervention
comme si c'était hier
mes filles à l'époque avait trois ans et
six mois j'étais à l'époque directeur
directrice de solutions e-business au
niveau européen et on roulante en
7digital d'aujourd'hui je travaillais
beaucoup je voyage et souvent je dormais
peu
j'arrivais à tout gérer aussi j'étais
pas très confortable avec l'exercice
personnel comme qu'on attendait de moi
mais en même temps je me souvenais d'un
témoignage d'une de mes aînés très
profond qui m'avait touché qui m'avait
encouragé et du coup je me suis lâché je
me suis lancé et j'ai parlé de ma
culpabilité de ma culpabilité de ne pas
élever mes filles dans les standards que
m'avait inculqué ma mère qui était
pourtant une femme très indépendante qui
s'étant retrouvée veuve à 30 ans m'avait
lever tout seuls
j'ai expliqué comment tous les jours je
m'attachais à définir mes propres
critères de ce qui était important dans
mon rôle de femme est dans mon rôle
d'épousé j'ai dit que j'arrivais petit à
petit à me délester de toute une série
de standards
inutile contraignant qui entravaient ma
liberté mon discours a fait mouche et
elles ont été nombreuses à la sortie à
venir discuter avec moi et me dire
qu'elle aussi elle traînait leur
culpabilité comme un boulet elles m'ont
dit qu'elle avait souvent un entourage
bien pensants qui chaque fois qu'un
petit incident se passait dans leur vie
un enfant malade par exemple lire leur
rappeler que peut-être elle négligé leur
rôle de mère alors pendant les vingt ans
qui ont suivi j'ai eu je suis intervenu
souvent sur le sujet des femmes
j'ai essayé d'apporter ma pierre à
l'édifice j'ai essayé de promouvoir des
fameux les faits j'ai poussé certaines
allées au bout de leur potentiel pas
peut-être pas suffisamment mais en tout
cas les ont toutes réussi mais je me
suis aussi lassé de cette discussion sur
les femmes dans l'entreprise et leur
représentation dans le pouvoir parce que
j'ai eu l'impression d'une discussion
sans fin et sans combattante
je m'explique vingt ans après nous en
sommes toujours à peu près 10% de femmes
dans les comités de direction des
grandes entreprises
vingt ans après quand vous regardez le
classement des 100 meilleurs signaux de
la harvard business review de 2016
il ya deux femmes vingt ans après on est
toujours à moins de 20 % de filles dans
les grandes écoles d'ingénieurs date ans
après cherchez donc une fondatrice qui
est créé une licorne de ces startups
évalué à plus d'un milliard de dollars
et quand vous regardez le palmarès des
startups à fort potentiel ils sont il
ressemble hélas tristement à la liste
des patrons du cac 40 pour ce qui
représente la représentation féminine et
d'ailleurs il ya 3 % de femmes qui sont
patrons de son investissement dans le
venture capital les femmes ne sont pas
là où se fait et se fait le monde de
demain alors plus perturbant encore il
ya serré et ses discussions avec des
femmes plus jeunes et j'en ai une entête
en particulier c'était dans un cabinet
très réputé
de la place parisienne des jeunes femmes
extrêmement diplômés et après m'avoir
écouté ils m'ont dit que mon combat pour
les femmes et le pouvoir était le combat
d'une autre génération qu'elle avait
d'autres idéaux et que la qualité ou de
vie au quotidien et est centrale et
qu'il était hors de question qu'elle
mette plus d'énergie que de nécessaire
pour créer vire gravir les échelons de
leur cabinet j'avoue que je suis sorti
très déprimé de la discussion
et pas seulement parce que je m'étais
fait traiter de dinosaures mais aussi
parce que je me suis dit que nous les
femmes de ma génération on avait sans
doute sérieusement raté notre devoir de
transmission et puis que l'on donnait
peut-être raison à ces hommes rétrograde
qui disait que on investissait trop sur
l'éducation des finis ma fille agathe au
début de cette année est revenu un jour
très remonté d'une classe d'anglais sont
professeurs leur avait elle m'a dit
maman
il faut qu'on parle des femmes dans
l'entreprise il faut qu'on parle du
féminisme
notre prof d'anglais qui est un réel
matches aux as nous a soumis un texte du
new york times sur le féminisme a
commenté les garçons s'en sont emparés
c'est devenu une grosse blague et nous
les filles dans la salle on a été nuls
en fait l'article été moins dramatique
que son titre ne pouvait le laisser
envisager féminisme is lost watts n'a
fini le féminisme est maintenant en fait
l'auteur élaboré sur la différence
d'attitude sur le féminisme entre une
hillary clinton fameux blanche déjà au
pouvoir
briguant la responsabilité suprême dans
son pays et puis la réalité de la
défense des droits des femmes vu du
point de vue de les lectrices de la
classe moyenne américaine qu'elle soit
noire qu'elle soit blanche les droits de
la femme peut-être mais à condition
d'avoir d'abord un travail et un salaire
décent et finalement peu leur importe et
les énormités proférées par un donald
trump elles ont voté pour lui s'il
faisait partie là
solution alors devant le désarroi de ma
fille sur ce féminisme planté je me suis
reposé le sujet de la gouvernance du
monde des entreprises je me suis posé la
question de la place des femmes et je me
suis dit que peut-être que sûrement
d'abord le sujet était aussi important
aujourd'hui qu'hier mais que peut-être
ce n'était plus un sujet de droit mais
un sujet de devoir parler du devoir
aujourd'hui c'est un peu compliqué et
puis d'ailleurs qui suis-je pour donner
des leçons à qui que ce soit et en
particulier aux femmes à qui on en donne
beaucoup mais moi je me refuse à vous
regarder les femmes
en tous les cas de nos sociétés de nos
civilisée de nos sociétés comme des
victimes elles ont trop de talent ils
ont trop de potentiel
et puis les enjeux sont là quand on
regarde notre monde
quand on regarde les impacts de la
technologie sur nos sociétés on en a on
à l'impact des technologies sur l'emploi
l'impact du d la pollution sur et les
enjeux environnementaux quand on pense à
la progression des inégalités dans le
monde il ya des problématiques énormes
auxquelles il faut que nous apportions
des solutions les femmes qui ne sont pas
assez présentes dans les cercles de
l'innovation dans les cercles du pouvoir
politique ou ou dans l'entreprise ne
sont pas partie prenante de la création
de ces solutions
le sujet n'est pas de savoir si il faut
que l'on fasse quelque chose pour
qu'elle faisait plus une part de 7 2 7
de ce travail
la question c'est de savoir comment on
fait pour qu'elle assume la
responsabilité qu'elles doivent aller
aux générations futures
en me les rencontres qui m'ont marqué
dans ma vie il ya eu celle avec l'épousé
du président sud africain thabo mbeki
chanel mbeki quand je les rencontre
était une femme d'un certain âge tout
frêle mais on sentait une forte
détermination
un certain nombre de femmes avaient été
rassemblés autour d'elle pour une visite
officielle et au bout d'un moment elle a
pris la parole est à nous a raconté son
histoire
elle nous a raconté son combat avec les
hommes pour la libération de son pays
à ce moment là il n'y avait juste aucune
différence entre les hommes et les
femmes
et puis est arrivé le moment de la paix
et le moment de reconstruire ce pays
pour le futur hélas les femmes ont eu
une bataille supplémentaires à livrer
c'était celle de rester dans le game de
rester dans le jeu pour anne l 1 bis qui
il était évident que dans un pays qui
était ravagé par la violence qui avait
tant d'enjeux sur la construction des
infrastructures de l'éducation
les femmes qui étaient souvent le pilier
central des familles leur pivot devait
avoir une voix sur ce que devait être
les priorités et comment les construire
et du coup elle s'est battue avec
d'autres femmes pour que la nouvelle
convention d'afrique du sud réserve une
place au parlement pour qu'ils aient une
capacité à construire les solutions
alors qu'est-ce qui va pas après des
années de revendications
après des années d'incitation
d'encouragement est-ce que l'on peut
réellement se dire que 2% 3 % 10 % sont
les la bonne mesure du talent des femmes
et de leur envie d'avoir une voix bien
sûr que non
au moment où les hommes eux-mêmes les
sommes les plus jeunes se posent la
question en disant mais où est donc le
problème c'est que finalement c'est dans
la tête des femmes qu'il a quelque chose
à débloquer pourquoi ont-elles tant de
problèmes avec les mots pouvoir et
ambition alors je pense que c'est parce
que les femmes les filles ont le choix
important conscient à faire bien plus
tôt dans leur vie que ne le font les
hommes dans nos sociétés quand on éteint
un garçon on suit la voie de la carrière
professionnelle sans même y penser
on verra après pour une femme
le choix se pose au moment où bien
souvent se pose aussi la perspective de
créer une famille et d'avoir des enfants
et du coup le choix de la carrière ne
peut pas être un choix par défaut
ça doit être un choix conscient un choix
qui repose je le crois sur ses pots
propre raison sur ses propres arguments
et au moment de ce choix du coup trois
démons vienne susurré aux femmes souvent
qu'elles doivent renoncer
le premier des démons se nourrit d'une
idée fausse de du chemin d'accès au
pouvoir
une idée simpliste beaucoup d'entre
elles disent moi je veux pas faire
carrière parce que pour ça il faut faire
de la politique
alors je crois que c'est une fausse
barbe c'est souvent de la peur je pense
que c'est surtout une fausse analyse est
que dans la réalité il ya très peu de
ces univers où l'intrigué se substitue
au talent d'ailleurs cessé univers là
qu'il faut fuir ce n'est pas le
challenge en fait dans la plupart des
cas bien sûr qu'on reconnaît le vrai
leadership le vrai la vraie capacité de
quelqu'un a contribué plus que les
autres au service des autres parce que
c'est ça aussi le pouvoir c'est à la
fois une école du dépassement de soi au
quotidien mais c'est surtout aussi le
vrai pouvoir
la volonté de contribuer plus au service
des autres le deuxième des mon président
autour de ce tout dont on dit quand on
leur dit qu'elles ne peuvent pas la voir
alors comprenez quand vous faites une
carrière professionnelle
vous ne pouvez pas être une bonne mère
quand vous faites une carrière
professionnelle
vous ne pouvez pas être féminine avoir
les atouts de la blache jolie et belle
compagne comprendre si vous êtes un
patron
au féminin vous êtes forcément agressive
et autoritaire alors l'image on peut en
reparler est ce que c'est vraiment
important ce qui est vraiment important
évidemment c'est de ne pas renoncer à
l'essentiel l'essentiel d'avoir à la
fois une vie personnelle et une ambition
professionnelle et là au risque de
choquer je vais dire que aujourd'hui en
les femmes ne sont pas dans une
situation si différente en tous les cas
dans nos sociétés si différentes des
hommes les hommes modernes aussi ont
envie d'avoir une vie familiale de
participer à la vie et à l'éducation de
leurs enfants on est plus à la fin du
19e siècle il xxème siècle pardon où les
hommes partaient en carrière
professionnelle comme on partait à la
guerre et donc il s'agit de définir ses
propres règles le troisième démons se
nourrit de cette idée insidieuse qui se
développe au fil de ses programmes sur
la parité et la mixité
les femmes ne seraient pas encore prête
il faudrait encore pas mal de temps pour
qu'elles soient plus nombreuses
et puis il leur faudrait pas mal de
coaching pour qu'enfin elle puisse y
arriver
alors je dis stop arrêtons cette
victimisation condescendante non les
femmes n'ont pas besoin d'apprendre à
négocier croyez pas dans vos
environnements elles sont des masters à
ça
l'ambition c'est le désir ardent
d'arriver à quelque chose
le pouvoir c'est la capacité d'influencé
de décider d'un pacte est néanmoins on a
tous eu besoin à un moment donné d'avoir
un petit coup de pouce pour choisir le
chemin le plus difficile celui qui va
être le plus gratifiant celui qui aura
le plus d'impact
alors faisons taire les démons mais et
vous vous qu'il y avait des filles et
femmes des amis qui ont du talent en qui
vous avez confiance
qu'est ce que vous leur dites quand
elles viennent vous voir et qu'elle vous
demande votre avis sur une promotion
pour leur propose une promotion qui fera
que pendant un certain temps il faudra
qu'elle soit 5 jours par semaine hors du
foyer familial
qu'est ce que vous leur dites quand
elles vous disent moi j'aimerais bien
monter une entreprise mais il va falloir
que je me contre consacre à dix mille
pour cent
est ce que vous leur dites fais
attention tu as une famille quand même
ou est ce que vous leur dites tu as
raison tu mérite ça tu vas y arriver et
tu trouvera des solutions
et qu'est ce que vous faites quand elles
viennent vous voir dans leur chemin
parce qu'elles ont des doutes parce
qu'elles ont des difficultés est ce que
vous leur dites fait le choix tu peux
arrêter ou est ce que vous leur dites
continue trouve des solutions qu elle
potentiel n'arrête pas pour des
mauvaises raisons et puis finalement
qu'est ce que vous faites vous au
quotidien pour que le monde bénéficie
d'une voix plus féminine pour le futur
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]